stop stop
stop after she tried stealing an old
woman's car keys this Florida woman
instead ued her game by stealing a
deputy's patrol car she let officials on
a high-speed chase that proved to be
deadly don't man she just got in my car
took
off eastbound on Highway 40 passing the
sub
station and the wasn't her first tangle
with the law either
this is her criminal
history this is
it criminal
history
Z on February 1st Maran County sheriff's
deputies responded to an emergency call
in a wind Dixie parking lot they gotten
reports of a woman who had attempted to
steal another woman's car keys body
camera video shows a deputy respond to
the scene to confront the woman later
identified as Kendra
Boon over to the back video shows the
deputy ask Boon to come to the back of
the squad but instead she climbs in
through the passenger side
window
no
finally the deputy is able to open the
driver's side door but Boon takes off a
split second later stop stop
stop seconds after that another Squad is
on her tail as the Chase
Begins don't man she just got in my car
took
off eastbound on Highway 40 passing the
sub station
Boon LED First Responders on a
high-speed chase that ended with her
colliding into a pickup truck she died
and so did two others who were inside
that truck a third person was taken to
the hospital in critical condition in a
press conference releasing the body
camera recording Maran County Sheriff
Billy Woods straight up calls Boon a
moron during that incident after he
arrived a moron decided to steal his
Patrol vehicle which ultimately ended up
resulting in us chasing
them and then in a tragic
accident where two
individuals were killed because of that
moron that's not the last time Woods
gets feisty he gets tense when a
reporter asks about Department policy
sherff what is the the Department's
policy on the cars running or not
running when when your Deputy leaves the
vehicle because it seems like the car
was running and she had access to drive
away in it I have a feeling y'all going
to push my buttons that
means okay that doesn't play a factor
into
anything this moron stole a police
vehicle and killed two human beings what
my policies are what the procedures are
mean nothing Boon's WAP sheet included
13 felony charges nine misdemeanors and
two convictions she even had a pass
charge in Maran County fleeing and
eluding oh that's a shock I'm almost 60
years old I can't do in Flagler County
Florida a man in a Grateful Dead t-shirt
rushes at a couple with a knife in hand
the stabbing caught on security camera
footage keep her eyes on the right side
of your screen that's Eric gabini the
man who told a sheriff's deputy he was
too old for this well as security cam
video shows us it was g deini Who rushed
toward a couple who were walking through
a neighborhood video shows gabini
approach the man and square him up we've
stopped the video here before things get
too physical but sheriff's deputies
reports gabini slashed the victim
several times after that he got in his
Jeep and drove off this body camera
recording shows what happened when
officials caught up with him what what's
going on I was driving by I see this
girl walking I said hey me Ro she said
something stupid C to me so that's see
him right there he started talking meide
P what's up I walked up on start
swinging on me H me on the ground Lally
I was he was on toping me beating on me
I P my little SCE time just SCH off if
gab Bean's story is hard to follow
that's because it doesn't quite match up
with the security footage we showed you
earlier according to the Flagler County
Sheriff's Office gabini was driving
around in a neighborhood and saw a
couple walking he approached the woman
multiple times asking her to get into
his car and this part he does admit to
let me get this straight so why were why
were you in that area in the first I
live here go okay so you live over there
yeah I live three you you don't know
this girl from any you never seen her
before life I've never seen any of these
people so why did you offer her a ride
ride I do that need to ride in the store
or something I'm going that way did was
she in distress did she to help she just
walking no I think she she was walking
by I just she want pick people up and
give but here's where the story differs
officials say gabini parked his Jeep and
rushed toward the couple confronting the
man and stabbing him several times but
according to gabini it was the man who
attacked him I was just friend where is
that at now top of Street backed up that
way but the neighbor see he came out see
that guy on top of me beating at me I
couldn't I couldn't I mean I couldn't
get any L me okay what the knife is a
couple streets down no it's in there
it's okay it's just a little thing like
little Ed for work fish like a pocket
knife or like a biging I use it for
fishing and who who is she to you nobody
you don't know her I don't know these
people I was driving by her and say you
need a ride ask her for a ride cuz she's
walking down the street dude was behind
in front of her I was saying you want
ride some I'm going out way in store she
said something I'm St he said something
I came back CU asked him what he just
jumped on me be be he had on the ground
he's a young kid gab Bean's inconsistent
story continues were you on flip I went
back no I I went back turned parked cuz
they were talking shit to me I was like
going to find out what's going on I was
trying to stop to instigate it he
started pounding on me okay okay I lost
I lost my scripts everything so that's
why I'm squinting right now I can't see
okay so so you drove so you drove you
drove past them and then you I drove she
was walking like 30 ft behind him just
walking okay so they were walking on the
street they weren't in the driveway
walking down this way I was going this
way I turned back around she said
something I like she wanted to ride or
something so I stopped you start fre I
didn't know they were together okay you
started freaking so so you drove past
and then you backed up no I just turn
off okay so you drove you drove past
them you turned back around and then you
re-engaged with them yeah well I was
were you on foot at that point or were
you in the I got out walked up to him
like what's going on he started swinging
on me man gde beanie says he was the one
who was attacked yeah cuz he thought I
was with his girlfriend I said I know
your girlfriend I'm sorry I'll leave and
couldn't get him offing I'm on the
ground Lally on my how when you
approached her or him like how were how
did you do it like were you running were
you park I walked up to him walked up
right up to me man I was like well I'm
just trying to figure out what's going
on you know I didn't trying to start no
anybody I was just going to the store
and back that's all I was trying to
do where where are you hurt at I'm not
really hurt little beat up I just can't
see I go back and get my glasses man he
says he's a good guy and I'm a good guy
I work every day man my before admitting
the knife was in his car where's the
knife at there it's in a it's in a
garbage and thing that's he then gives
better directions for the deputy to find
the weapon you going to take me to jail
no you're just detained right now we
have to figure out what's going on we
have someone over there I don't want to
problem with these people if I could
talk to her or him I just squash it
right now cuz I'm cool with everybody
I'm almost 60 years old I can't be doing
me put your freedom please all right can
I get the knife out of your car so I can
look at it oh absolutely yeah please uh
please let me call my girl man my wallet
I got money my wallet where where I just
want to grab the knife right now where
is it at it's in a garbage bag in the on
the where the shifter is garbage bag is
hanging from it it's in there okay this
time gabini was telling the truth and
the knife is recovered from his
Jeep
[Applause]
a free I radio app
all because of this security camera
video showing what really happened
gabini was later charged with aggravated
battery with a dead weapon listen
working here covering the body cams that
we do we know how crazy and
unpredictable life can get that's why
when things go wrong like a work injury
car accident or even Social Security
Disability issue you need a champion in
your corner enter py hockey geordano the
PowerHouse legal team known for turning
the tables in your favor and they're not
just lawyers either they're Relentless
Advocates fighting tooth and nail for
your rights and they make sure that
after an accident you never have to
recover alone their track record alone
speaks volumes they've secured more than
$1 billion dollar for more than 100,000
injured and disabled clients when you
hire pondley hockey you're not just
being represented by a single attorney
either actually you're getting access to
the entire team with more than 250 years
of combined courtroom experience you
can't ask for much more than that so if
if you're ever injured at work you can
go to
www.p ponle hockey.com
ELC bodycam or pick up the phone and
call them at 833
66944 3 all right let's get back to the
video let's go put your hand let's go
get your hand off of me now put your
hands off get your hand off of me now
you cop that turn around Put Your Hands
by your back turn around put your hands
behind your
back in Glenn County Georgia a man with
mental health issues is slammed To The
Ground by a police officer his arrest is
captured on body cam turn around put
your hands behind your back now
no turn around put your hands behind
your back turn around put your hands
behind your back turn around put your
hands behind your back it happened on
February 1st when police say the man was
standing too close to the roadway body
camera video shows an officer approach
him and ask him to step onto the
sidewalk stay on the sidewalk up here so
we're not in the road but pretty quickly
things get tense when the man doesn't
cooperate right
away don't roll don't roll up on me
don't put your hands on me back up on
the sidewalk so we can talk back up stop
hold hold on now stop disrespect stop if
you decide to fight me if you decide to
fight me my dog's coming
out let's go let's go up on the sidewalk
let's go disrespecting me now I'm
back you disrespecting me now I'm
telling you I'm telling you oh you
pulling my chain off I'm telling you you
trying to pull my chain off I'm telling
you you trying to put my chain off up
next the officer attempts to restrain
the man slamming him to the ground let's
go put your hand let's go get your hand
off of me now put your hands off get
your hand off of me now turn around put
your hands behind your back turn around
put your hands behind your back after
that a tussle is caught on
Camp stop stop turn around put your
hands behind your
back no no no hold up my pants turn
around put your hands behind your back
now soon the officer brings out a taser
and shoots it at the suspect back now
coming turn around put your hands behind
your back turn around put your hands
behind your back put your hands behind
your back did not see my pants put your
hands behind your back stop
stop
do what the man just do what the man
says
Tas
yeah just be quiet
say the recording continues on with the
man still on the
ground all right hold them out hold
they'll stay right there keep them right
there for a minute these crows
bleeding before they go will you grab
their names please CU they help
me you know yall you know what going to
happen you guys start got oh what's your
name officer
msed my
leg man you see my toe stop man stop
stop stop don't try and grab him I how
you ended up down here in the first
place cuz you grabbed me soon officers
on the scene lift up the suspect and
move him into the back of a squad
car
way bring bring your foot out try on
that you want to try roll yeah we can
try and roll them up on side yeah
go he's going to have to go in your car
okay obviously can't put him in
mine let's go going go that back yep
you're going to be going up to the
hospital one way or another let's
go hold the come let's go hold the let's
go hey shoot one of these crackers when
you suppos
to shoot one of them in they out let's
go I do it off
do now you got some good ones I think
these some good
ones I really do think they
good sit down told my told my told
man the suspect's mother eventually
arrived on the scene and told
investigators he suffers from severe
mental illness even still he faces a
felony charge of abs destruction or
hindering a law enforcement officer
reporting for long crime I'm Sierra
Gillespie